Let's review how we
transfer stitches manually.
Using the double-eye needle,
we position it opposite the ribber
and insert the hook of the needle
in the hole of the tool.
Pull up the needle and put
the stitch behind the latch.
Push down on the needle to slip
the stitch onto the tool.
Then slip the stitch
to the other end of the tool.
Position the eye of the tool over the hook
of the target needle
and slip the stitch off.
Now we can do the same thing
by using two transfer tools.
Position the eyes of the first tool
over the needles to be transferred.
Pull up to get the stitches
behind the latches.
Push down to transfer
the stitches to the tool.
Insert the prongs of a second tool
in the stitches and transfer
the stitches to the second tool.
Set the first tool aside.
Slip the eyes of the tool over the hooks
to the target needles and slip
the stitches onto the needles.